Buonasera, dunque siamo alla seconda tappa di questo nostro viaggio tra gli uomini che
hanno fatto il risorgimento, che hanno fatto l'Italia Unita e stasera raccontiamo un altro
pezzo di risorgimento attraverso la figura, la personalità di Vittorio Emanuele II. Vittorio
Emanuele è probabilmente un personaggio di stazza inferiore rispetto a Cavour, rispetto
a Garibaldi dal punto di vista intellettuale, politico, anche umano, per quel che valgono
questi giudizi, si capisce, però è stato un protagonista comunque, è stato un protagonista
nel bene e nel male e attraverso l'analisi del personaggio, delle sue reazioni, delle
sue decisioni, delle sue idee, si scoprono tanti retroscena del risorgimento. Vittorio Emanuele
è forse fra questi personaggi di cui parliamo quello per cui è più vistoso lo scarto fra
la leggenda costruita dalla propaganda e l'uomo come si rivela attraverso le testimonianze
di chi l'ha conosciuto e attraverso le sue stesse carte, la sua corrispondenza. Vittorio
Emanuele II una volta, adesso non so quanto sia ancora corrente il soprannome, ma era conosciuto
come il re galantuomo e questo appellativo forgiato dalla propaganda dinastica era corrente
già durante la sua vita. Poi in privato, e neanche tanto in privato, altri avevano su di
lui opinioni diverse. Non è detto che avessero ragione, sia chiaro, io però comincio lo stesso
dalle opinioni che sono in più vistoso contrasto con la leggenda del re galantuomo.
Nel 1867 il ministro degli esteri inglese, Lord Clarendon, è a Firenze. Firenze è capitale
d'Italia in quel momento, l'Italia è già unita da un pezzo, Vittorio Emanuele II è primo
re d'Italia, Cavour è già morto. A Firenze Lord Clarendon parla con i ministri e si informa
sull'opinione che hanno del re. Mi dissero, e da qui parte una citazione letterale, dice
Lord Clarendon, mi dissero che era ipocrita e ignorante, un intrigante che nessuno né stuomo
poteva servire senza danno per la sua reputazione. Tutti sono d'accordo nel giudicare il re un
imbecille, è un disonesto che mente con tutti. Questo dunque il parere dei ministri
che servivano al re Vittorio e che lavoravano con lui in quegli anni a Firenze. Vedremo
poi quanto questo parere fosse di parte, lo era certamente, era il parere di ministri
che dovevano lavorare con un re che aveva imparato solo fino a un certo punto il mestiere
di re costituzionale e fare il ministro di un re che, come vedremo, tendeva a fare politica
per conto suo, infischiandosene spesso allegramente del governo, delle sue opinioni, eccetera, non
era certamente facile. Che fosse ignorante, come dissero i ministri a Lord Clarendon, è
possibile, non è forse nemmeno così rilevante. Tuttavia, siccome i pareri altrui sono sempre
interessanti, vediamo i pareri che gli insegnanti di Vittorio Emanuele davano su di lui ragazzino
a scuola. Vittorio Emanuele a scuola seguiva un programma severissimo, ebbe un'istruzione
in innumerevoli materie, con una scaletta militaresca, e però i giudizi dei suoi insegnanti, come
risultano agli atti, sono del tipo, è sempre addormentato, lavora poco o nulla, lavora con
somma noia e indolenza. Con tutto questo gli facevano fare gli esami, poi lo promuovevano
di solito, ma a margine del verbale scrivevano, può dirsi che il principe agli esami non ha
risposto nulla di nulla. Questo può essere consolante per i più giovani fra noi, insomma
si può sempre... Detto questo, per esempio, un punto a favore di Vittorio Emanuele è che
ha avuto un'educazione in italiano, in lingua italiana voglio dire, diversamente da Cavour
che nei primi anni era stato educato in francese, Vittorio Emanuele parla e scrive piuttosto
volentieri in italiano, non un grande italiano, ci capiterà di avere qualche esempio, però
certamente la sua educazione, se non altro, è avvenuta in quella lingua. È una questione
di generazione, Vittorio è più giovane, Vittorio è nato nel 20, quindi ha 10 anni
meno di Cavour, ha 13 anni meno di Garibaldi, e questo uno non lo tiene sempre presente perché
per noi queste sono delle icone, dei monumenti, tutti uguali in qualche modo, invece quando
pensiamo al rapporto fra il re e il suo primo ministro, o fra il re e Garibaldi, ecco
bisogna anche ricordarsi che il re è nettamente più giovane di loro. Anche se possono sembrare
pettegolezzi indegni della storia, mi vorrei soffermare un istante sull'aspetto fisico
di Vittorio Emanuele, perché l'aspetto fisico di un re è qualcosa che può avere una rilevanza
politica. Quando un re va in giro per il mondo, va ospite nelle altre corti, ebbene viene giudicato
per il suo comportamento, per la sua buona educazione, tanta o poca, pochissima nel caso
di Vittorio, dicono tutti, ma anche per il suo aspetto fisico. E del resto tutti abbiamo
presente la maschera di Vittorio Emanuele, questa facciona con questi lineamenti così
marcati. Ecco, è molto curioso il fatto che mi è capitato di imbattermi in commenti
sull'aspetto di Vittorio Emanuele, molto simili pur venendo da fonti diverse. Lo scultore
Marocchetti dice di Vittorio, ha in sé qualcosa di selvaggio, di pittoresco, che non manca
di grandezza, e fa pensare a un re uno, a un capo barbarico. Ecco, voi capite che avendo
trovato questa citazione sono rimasto abbastanza stupito quando ho scoperto che, allorché Vittorio
è andato in Inghilterra, un famoso diarista della corte inglese, Greville, scrive di lui
sembra un capo di Eruli o di Longobardi. Naturalmente questo non era necessariamente un buon biglietto
da visita nelle corti europee di metà ottocento, ma è interessante questa convergenza. Greville
aggiunge il tipo più depravato e dissoluto del mondo. Qui mi fermerò un istante su un
pettegolezzo, anche perché ieri abbiamo parlato di Cavour e qualcuno mi ha giustamente
rimproverato di non aver accennato neanche di sfuggita alla contessa di Castiglione e
relativi pettegolezzi. Quindi stasera mi concederò qualche pettegolezzo in più. Molti
sapranno che corre un pettegolezzo secondo cui in realtà Vittorio Emanuele non era figlio
di Carlo Alberto, ma era stato sostituito nella culla. E questo nasceva proprio dalla vistosa
differenza di stile e di comportamento fra l'ascetico Carlo Alberto e il carnalissimo, invece,
Vittorio. Cos'era successo? Che in effetti è successo che quando Vittorio Emanuele era
appena nato è sfuggito per miracolo a un incendio nel quale è morta di ustioni la sua
balia. E a partire da questa vicenda è poi entrata in circolo in seguito la leggenda
secondo cui in realtà il bambino era morto e lo avevano sostituito con un altro.
Va detto che Vittorio Emanuele aveva un aspetto fisico, un modo di comportarsi pesantemente diverso
rispetto al suo padre austero e ascetico, ma se voi guardate i lineamenti non è detto che fosse
così. Provate a prendere, se vi capita a guardare su internet, una moneta di Carlo Alberto, coniato
ovviamente quando Vittorio era bambino, quindi senza nessuna possibile frode. Ecco, nelle monete di
Carlo Alberto si vede benissimo che il profilo di Carlo Alberto era singolarmente simile a quello
di suo figlio. Cioè singolarmente, perché singolarmente? Ovviamente simile, ecco. Aggiungerei
un'altra cosa, se facciamo un pettegolezzo facciamolo fino in fondo. Sarebbe stato particolarmente
assurdo che sostituissero questo bambino nella culla, anche nell'ipotesi che fosse morto, perché
questo succede nel 21, quando Carlo Alberto è un giovane principe, lontanissimo dal trono
ancora, è perfettamente in grado di fare altri figli, come infatti ne farà, e quindi
se anche gli fosse morto il primo genito in culla, l'idea che mettessero in piedi questa
macchinazione è pericolosissima, perché se qualcuno lo scopre che figura ci si fa poi,
ecco, per sostituire il bambino francamente è un'ipotesi così poco economica. Restiamo
per un momento al comportamento, alla buona educazione di Vittorio, ripeto, un po' per il divertimento
del pettegolezzo naturalmente, ma anche perché queste cose, quando riguardano un re, hanno
una valenza politica. Il re va in giro per le capitali europee e sovrani e ministri europei
prendono nota del tipo e del suo comportamento. Un altro giudizio al momento della sua visita
a Londra. Il re è di modi molto bruschi e dice qualsiasi cosa gli passa per la testa.
La sua conversazione è certo molto originale e spesso buffa, per quanto rozza e militaresca
al massimo grado. Quando va a Parigi, i commenti alla corte di Napoleone III sono dello stesso
tono. Il suo comportamento è molto rozzo e si racconta che dice cose irripetibili.
Lo dico, non lo dico, ma sì, mi accuserete di essere uno storico poco serio. All'imperatrice
Eugenia, moglie di Napoleone III, e questo lo confida la stessa imperatrice Eugenia, Vittorio
Emanuele dice che Parigi gli piace tantissimo. Ha scoperto che le Parigine non portano le
mutande. Testuale, è un cielo azzurro che si è aperto ai miei occhi. Vittorio Emanuele
è un uomo di robusti appetiti in tutti i sensi, è un uomo che ha innumerevoli relazioni,
figli illegittimi dappertutto. Si sparge già fin dai primi anni del suo regno la barzelletta
che corre in Piemonte e che è un re che ha saputo davvero essere il padre del suo popolo.
Gli si attaglia talmente che può averla messa in giro lui, secondo me. Dopodiché, di nuovo,
è un sovrano che ha degli appetiti, che li controlla poco, che non vede perché dovrebbe
controllarli, a rischio che questo politicamente gli si possa ritorcere contro. E' certamente uno
che parla senza pensarci, tanto lui è il re e può dire quello che vuole. Aggiungo ancora un
commento, stavolta cito un diplomatico francese, Lideville, che ho già citato ieri più volte,
che sul re afferma. Sua maestra sarda ama vantarsi, è poco amica della verità, è per di più assai
indiscreta. In ogni occasione Vittorio Emanuele parla delle sue venti ferite, in guerra si intende,
e fa volentieri il racconto favoloso dei pericoli che ha corso, sia in guerra che a caccia. Ognuno sa
tuttavia, che pur essendo coraggioso e persino temerario, il re di Sardegna è stato raramente
ferito. Quanto alle fortune amorose, ne parla con una franchezza e una disinvoltura che non sono degne
del suo soprannome di galantuomo. Il fatto più singolare si è che spesso confonde i successi avuti
con quelli che avrebbe voluto avere. Io spero che la parte più densa e carica di pettegolezzi
sia finita, ma è importante sapere che questo era l'uomo che doveva negoziare con D'Azeglio e con
Cavour e decidere che atteggiamento tenere con Garibaldi e che doveva tenersi buona la regina
d'Inghilterra e l'imperatore Napoleone III e che non sempre sapeva essere in quanto re diverso dall'uomo
che era nella sua vita privata. C'è almeno un caso in cui politicamente si arriva proprio all'urto
frontale fra i due profili, c'è un momento in cui lui è rimasto vedovo e sarebbe molto opportuno un
suo matrimonio con una principessa inglese. Sempre per la serie, ancora nell'ottocento si faceva la
diplomazia come ai vecchi tempi, come sotto l'antico regime, con i matrimoni dei re e dei principi. A questo
matrimonio il governo italiano tiene tantissimo e gli inglesi sono anche disposti a discuterne, però poi
quando interpellano la principessa Mary, la principessa Mary che ha conosciuto Vittorio risponde
sono convinta che è una brava persona, ma questo non basta a compensare la sua mancanza di principi e
di buone maniere. E come potrei mai rispettare e stimare un uomo così totalmente grossolano, uno che
non ha neppure la cortesia e la raffinatezza di un gentiluomo per compensare le sue debolezze?
Ecco, il matrimonio inglese ovviamente naufraga. Detto questo, io sono convinto che Vittorio
Emanuele con tutte le sue debolezze non sfigura nella compagnia di Cavour e di Garibaldi perché
anche se è certamente un politico di statura minore rispetto a loro, però è un uomo che si è
trovato in una posizione di grande potere in un momento delicatissimo e tutto sommato ha saputo
non perdere la testa, non cedere alle tentazioni e prendere poi quasi sempre le decisioni giuste
quando veramente era costretto a pensarci su e ad aprire gli occhi. Vittorio Emanuele diventerà
in un momento terribile, nel 1849 dopo Novara, dopo la fine disastrosa della prima guerra di
indipendenza. Suo padre Carlo Alberto ha dovuto abdicare e andarsene in esilio. Vittorio Emanuele
eredita quindi un paese sconfitto, un esercito, come dire, che ha sulle spalle l'onte di due
sconfitte catastrofiche, a Custozza e a Novara, e un'Austria trionfante che detta le condizioni.
E lui ha 29 anni. E quanto al profitto dei suoi studi possiamo immaginarlo per l'appunto.
Questo è un momento cruciale su cui la propaganda poi risorgimentale insisterà moltissimo.
si crea, cioè, l'immagine, non voglio dire la leggenda, ma l'immagine raccontata poi
nei libri di scuola, negli affreschi dei palazzi pubblici e così via, del giovane re che di
fronte al maresciallo Radetzky che gli dice, sì re, abolite lo statuto, il che vuol dire
tornate alla monarchia assoluta, fatela finita con questo esperimento liberale, ecco, di fronte
al maresciallo Radetzky il re si oppone fieramente e rifiuta di abolire lo statuto e quel po'
di democrazia parlamentare che esisteva nel suo regno. Ecco, in realtà non è una leggenda,
perché Vittorio davvero alla fine non ha abolito lo statuto e ha saputo governare anche
in quegli anni difficili come sovrano costituzionale. Gli è costato, gli sarebbe costato meno probabilmente
dar retta agli austriaci e ai reazionari e dare un colpo di spugna e tornare indietro. Lui
per i suoi gusti personali ne avrebbe fatto volentieri a meno di una camera di fronte a
cui il governo doveva rispondere. E non c'è dubbio che in quei mesi lui si fa sentire in
giro dicendo delle cose terrificanti. All'ambasciatore francese Vittorio dice che suo padre, Carlo
Alberto, ingannava tutti col suo regime deplorevole e che il fantasma dell'indipendenza italiana
è stato fatale al nostro sventurato paese. All'ambasciatore austriaco dice delle cose
ancora più terribili. All'ambasciatore austriaco dice i democratici, canaglie, schiacciarli come
mosche, impiccarli tutti quanti. Ma il fatto è che Vittorio aveva questa grandissima capacità
che ai suoi ministri darà poi molto fastidio e lo fa giudicare un ipocrita, un falso, uno
che ti rovina la reputazione se ti fidi di lui, ma che in certi momenti gli viene invece
molto utile. Questa grandissima capacità di dire a tutti quello che volevano sentire.
E quindi con l'ambasciatore austriaco tranquillamente minaccia sfracelli contro i democratici.
Però poi se noi guardiamo i fatti, i fatti sono che Vittorio tiene in piedi lo statuto,
tiene in piedi il regime parlamentare, le elezioni, la bandiera tricolore che gli austriaci
sarebbero stati così contenti se fosse stata abolita in quanto proprio simbolo della lotta
per l'indipendenza italiana. E allora come si spiega? E gli storici non sono mica tanto
a loro agio di fronte a quest'uomo che quando uno sta a sentire quel che dice c'è da mettersi
le mani nei capelli. Ma poi se uno guarda quel che fa, ecco, in realtà c'è qualcosa di più
solido di quello che ci aspetteremo. In realtà Vittorio evidentemente è uno che non è un fanatico,
fanatico, ha buonsenso, gli piace regnare, gli piace comandare, ma nelle circostanze di quel
tempo si rende conto che se volesse fare il tiranno e abolire il liberalismo, ebbè si
tirerebbe addosso più fastidi che non a continuare a governare come re liberale. Non
ha voglia di fare quei passi, scatenare l'esercito nella repressione, poi quando ce n'è bisogno
in casi specifici lo fa naturalmente, quando a Genova c'è l'insurrezione, ebbene lì
si manda l'esercito e si spara con i cannoni, quando c'è l'insurrezione mazziniana, ma
tenendo però la barra dritta sul fatto che alcune cose di fondo il regime liberale e parlamentare,
quelli si rispettano.
Intendiamoci, bisogna anche aver chiaro cosa voleva dire il regime parlamentare garantito
dallo statuto nel Piemonte del 1848. Come ovunque in Europa non c'era il suffragio universale,
c'era un suffragio ristretto sulla base della proprietà, occorreva avere un certo livello
di proprietà e pagare un certo livello di tasse quindi per avere il diritto di voto. Questo
era normale peraltro nei regimi parlamentari ottocenteschi che quindi noi chiamiamo democrazie
con qualche esitazione, la battaglia per il suffragio universale sarà una battaglia lunga.
in Piemonte il regime è particolarmente ristretto, mi pare, non vorrei, non sono sicuro
al mille per mille ma l'ordia di grandezza è questo, che sia il 3% dei cittadini che ha
diritto di voto. Talmente è alto il livello di reddito fissato, ecco.
La cosa curiosa è che in questo modo la legge elettorale rappresenta l'opinione pubblica
più illuminata, perché sono precisamente i borghesi che hanno mezzi, gli stessi che hanno
studiato, che conoscono il mondo e che sono in linea con le opinioni liberali che sono quelle
dominanti nei paesi più avanzati dell'Europa di allora. C'è questo paradosso che se avessero
votato i contadini in massa, molto probabilmente avrebbero votato per il re, per l'altare, senza
farsi scrupoli, e invece la legge elettorale esistente, proprio perché è così restrittiva,
manda regolarmente alla Camera delle maggioranze abbastanza liberali, se non di sinistra. Il
meccanismo del voto è abbastanza chiaro. Dal Piemonte, con etale, in senso stretto, in genere
vengono soprattutto deputati liberali o di sinistra. Dalla Liguria vengono deputati di sinistra
normalmente, quelli più temuti chiaramente dal re. Per fortuna c'è la Savoia, dove
invece eleggono di solito deputati di estrema destra, e quindi si fa un qualche equilibrio.
Però queste Camere sono difficili da governare. Per fortuna lo Statuto permette al re di sciogliere
la Camera quando vuole. Non ha bisogno di nessun pretesto. Basta che decida di sciogliere
la Camera, la può sciogliere. E ovviamente convoca nuove elezioni. Queste elezioni erano
elezioni democratiche fino a un certo punto, e non solo perché votavano in pochi, ma anche
perché il Ministero mobilitava i prefetti per spiegare alla gente qual era il modo
giusto di votare, e insomma chi votava male rischiava poi di avere delle seccature. Insomma
quindi è una democrazia molto limitata, ben inteso. È una democrazia soprattutto in quanto
c'è comunque poi alla fine un Parlamento in cui si discute, e di fronte a cui il governo
è responsabile. Il re Vittorio a queste condizioni ci può anche stare. Quando la Camera non gli
piace la scioglie. E ha ben chiaro che se non ci fosse questa maledetta legge elettorale
così restrittiva per lui sarebbe perfino meglio. A un certo punto lo dice espressamente.
Darò il suffragio universale e andrò io stesso a parlare agli elettori, convinto che in questo
modo appunto avrà una Camera molto più malleabile e conservatrice di quella che è eletta da quei
pochi borghesi liberali che votano. E dunque qual è la posizione politica di Vittorio? Ieri
abbiamo raccontato quella di Cavour, liberale, ostile alla democrazia estrema, ostile ovviamente
ai rivoluzionari, ai mazziniani, ferocemente antisocialista e anticomunista, però anche
ostile al potere della sciabola, ai governi reazionari. Ecco Vittorio tutto sommato con fatica
riesce a stare abbastanza su questa linea. E questo è uno dei motivi fondamentali per
cui questa strana coppia, Vittorio e Camillo, ha funzionato pur fra litigi furibondi e nei
momenti cruciali ha preso le decisioni giuste. Poi ci sono le intemperanze verbali, naturalmente
le intemperanze verbali non per niente ho cominciato raccontando gli aneddoti perché
bisogna aver presente l'uomo e così quando gli parlano di Mazzini Vittorio e Emanuele non
fa nessuna fatica a dire in pubblico se riesco ad acciuffarlo lo impaglio. Però non
dimentichiamoci che Mazzini è un terrorista condannato a morte e quindi tutto sommato
anche l'idea di impagliarlo e esplorlo in un museo non è così stravagante come potrebbe
sembrare a noi oggi che Mazzini ce lo abbiamo nelle statue, nelle piazze. Il re dunque nonostante
tutto ha un suo solido buonsenso che gli permette di fare le scelte giuste nei momenti difficili
e ha un'altra grande capacità che è quella di farsi consigliare dalle persone giuste,
di scegliere dei ministri che sono tutto sommato le persone giuste, anche quando con loro poi
magari fa fatica a andare d'accordo. Nell'epoca che ci interessa qui Vittorio ha due primi
ministri che sono entrambi figure fondamentali, il D'Azeglio prima e poi più a lungo il Cavour.
Ed è molto curioso il tipo di rapporto personale che Vittorio ha con loro. Teniamo conto della
situazione appunto, lui è un re che se avesse voluto avrebbe anche potuto far la prova di
forza e abolirlo il Parlamento, invece non l'ha fatto. Nomina un governo che però deve
rispondere alle camere e quindi bisogna gestirla con una certa delicatezza la faccenda, il re non
può fare tutto quello che vuole, anzi il re dovrebbe starsene un po' nell'ombra in un regime
di questo tipo, invece lui è sempre abbastanza sulla scena. I rapporti con i suoi ministri
sono tempestosi, ma siamo pur sempre in una piccola capitale, in un piccolo regno dove
c'è una familiarità personale, dove tutti si parlano in dialetto e quando scrivono, scrivono
magari in italiano ma sotto il dialetto si vede. Ecco il tono dei rapporti personali fra il
re Vittorio e i suoi ministri è qualcosa che vale la pena di andare a vedere nelle lettere
per esempio, per raggiungere una nota al quadro. Vedete come scriveva D'Azeglio? Mi
voglia sempre tanto bene quanto io ce ne voglio a lei. D'Azeglio, incoraggiato, ogni tanto gli
dà dei consigli per sentirsi rispondere dal re. So cosa mi fo e a dirle il vero non sono
molto amatore di consigli. Quando ne avrò bisogno glielo chiederò. Con tutto ciò non mi voglia
male. Ciao Massimo. Scritto così. Il rapporto con Cavour è più o meno sullo stesso stile.
Raccontiamo un esempio. Cavour nel 52, il primo ministro da poco, deve nominare, udite udite,
il presidente della Camera. E questa nomina della presidenza della Camera è controversa. Cavour
in quel momento sta facendo una delle più ardite manovre politiche della sua vita parlamentare,
quella che poi è passata alla storia come il connubio. Cosa vuol dire in sostanza il
connubio? In Parlamento c'è Cavour con i suoi fedeli una discreta maggioranza, tutto sommato,
parlamentare di liberali conservatori. E poi c'è un grosso nucleo consistente di sinistra,
non estremisti mazziniani chiaramente, ma liberali democratici come si diceva allora,
guidati da Rattazzi. A un certo punto Cavour fa questa manovra di allearsi con Rattazzi e quindi
con i democratici. Manovra all'epoca estremamente discussa, criticata, eccetera. E uno degli elementi
di questa manovra è che Rattazzi, che era già ministro, deve diventare presidente della
Camera. Lo fanno senza dir niente al re, lo votano, tutto legale, il Parlamento vota Rattazzi
presidente della Camera. Quando il re Vittorio viene a saperlo, è furibondo con Cavour, perché a lui
Rattazzi non piace per niente in quel momento, poi imparerà ad apprezzarlo, ma in quel momento l'idea
di un democratico, che non solo è ministro, e già questo è grave, ma per di più lo fanno presidente
della Camera, ecco questo al re dà veramente molto fastidio. E quindi scrive al Cavour, che è molto
addolorato per la nomina del Rattazzi. Inoltre, qui è il re che scrive, io sono poco divertito di
vedere costantemente delle divergenze d'opinione nel ministero, e che un ministro abbia cercato
questa nomina, la quale non sarà da tutti ben capita, né all'interno né all'estero, se lei me ne
avesse parlato prima, e che il fatto che pareva lontano non fosse stato invece così repentito,
voleva dire repentino evidentemente, ma gli è scappato di scrivere così, repentito, cioè
improvviso, non repentino, ecco, le avrei date le mie ragioni, era Tazzi stesso, lui scrive era
Tazzi con una tisola, di cui conosco la prudenza, le avrebbe capite per primo, dunque il re fu
ribondo, però ecco anche il realismo. A questo punto il Parlamento ha votato e non si può più
far niente. Ora ciò è fatto ed egli deve stare. Ciao caro Cavour, abbia più confidenza in me un'altra
volta. Il rapporto fra il re e Cavour è un rapporto tale che ci si potrebbero scrivere dei romanzi
sopra, e fa la delizia naturalmente degli osservatori del tempo, degli osservatori stranieri
in particolare. È un rapporto tempestoso, chi di voi c'era ieri sera sa che Cavour era un carattere
tutt'altro che facile da dominare, un carattere imperioso, in politica uno schiacciasassi che non
guardava in faccia a nessuno per arrivare dove voleva. Ecco, far politica con lui per il re era
tutt'altro che facile, però per fortuna il re tutto sommato non aveva tanta voglia di occuparsi
della gestione quotidiana degli affari, a lui piaceva andare a caccia. E dunque lascia mano libera
a Cavour, salvo, nei momenti importanti, scoprire che Cavour ha fatto qualcosa che a lui, Vittorio,
non piace per niente, è protestare. Tutti sono più o meno convinti all'epoca che il re non ama
per niente Cavour, anzi lo sopporta a fatica, lo detesta, ma non può fare a meno di lui,
perché Cavour ha una maggioranza così solida in Parlamento e nel Paese che senza Cavour
non si governa. Il re si vendica facendogli degli scherzi antipatici, per esempio lo invita
a cena, gli dice ecco qui c'è lo spezzatino di cervo e Cavour dice buono, buono, buono il cervo,
poi il re scrive agli amici dicendogli ho fatto mangiare il cavallo in realtà e ha anche detto
che era buono. Cavour ogni tanto si dimette nei momenti drammatici dopo Villa Franca, per
esempio, quando sembra che tutto vada a finire in rovina, Cavour si dimette. In quei momenti
la reazione istintiva del re Vittorio è di dire ah, finalmente mi sono liberato di
lui. Nel 59 quando Cavour si dimette dopo Villa Franca il re Vittorio fa sapere a un
ambasciatore straniero che lui è veramente sollevato e che Cavour è finito, la sua epoca
è finita. E la stessa occasione in cui, come raccontavamo ieri, Cavour fu ribondo perché
Napoleone III ha fatto l'armistizio a Villa Franca con gli austriaci e il re Vittorio non
si è opposto. Ecco, Cavour in presenza del re prende a calci le seggiole e insulta il
re chiamandolo traditore e gli ricorda che i re in certi momenti devono anche saper abdicare.
Dopo quell'esperienza Vittorio confiderà che Cavour è pazzo, che è un tiranno insopportabile
e che con lui non si può andare avanti. E qualcuno, non so più se è il minghete, comunque
qualcuno dice, ho visto il re, da quando Cavour si è dimesso, sembra uno scolaretto
in vacanza. Se non che cosa succede? Che non c'è nessuna maggioranza senza Cavour e quindi
Vittorio è costretto a richiamarlo. E siccome intanto però le cose vanno avanti, quelli
sono anni tempestosi in cui le cose avvengono con una rapidità stupefacente, appena finita
con questa delusione di Villa Franca, la seconda guerra di indipendenza, c'è pur sempre da
annettere la Lombardia e in realtà si annettono anche gli altri Ducati e una parte dello Stato
Pontificio. È un momento travolgente, avanzata delle idee risorgimentali e in quel momento
insomma il re e Cavour fanno subito la pace perché ci sono delle cose colossali da fare.
Scrivono al Papa per convincerlo a rinunciare spontaneamente a una parte dello Stato Pontificio
e Cavour fa appunto in quei mesi i suoi soliti miracoli e il re in quel momento è contentissimo.
Scrive, io e il maestro, il maestro sarebbe Cavour, lo chiama abitualmente così, nei momenti
buoni, io e il maestro siamo pronti a ogni cimento, anche a prendere il sole e la luna
con i denti. Si lascia prendere dall'entusiasmo dunque. Cavour era meno entusiasta, lavorava
con Vittorio, era costretto a farlo ovviamente. Il suo parere personale su questo re, appunto
capriccioso e difficile e poco leale con cui gli toccava lavorare, lo ha dato più di una
volta. Parere di Cavour sul re Vittorio scrivendo a un amico. Come rappresentante del principio
monarchico, come simbolo dell'unità, sono pronto a sacrificare al re la vita, le sostanze,
ogni cosa infine. Come uomo desidero da lui un solo favore, il rimanermene il più lontano
possibile. Ecco ma cos'è in sostanza, un po' si intuisce naturalmente, ma cerchiamo
di stringere, cos'è che rende veramente difficile per un primo ministro lavorare con un uomo come
Vittorio Emanuele II? In definitiva il punto cruciale è questo, che Vittorio Emanuele
II, re costituzionale, il cui governo deve rispondere alle camere, è continuamente tentato
di farsi la sua politica personale. In qualunque situazione c'è un governo che negozia, magari
con Napoleone III, magari con il Papa, che fa dei progetti di legge, magari anche difficili,
controversi, e Vittorio Emanuele è continuamente tentato di negoziare anche lui in segreto, senza
dirlo al ministro, per vedere convinto che magari lui arriva a fare qualcosa di più.
E' questo che ovviamente rende difficilissimo per un ministro governare con lui, perché
continuamente può succedere uno scandalo, continuamente si può scoprire che il governo
sta facendo una politica e il re non la sostiene, in realtà Sottobanco sta facendo una politica
diversa. Questo è pazzesco ovviamente, ed è il motivo per cui Cavour così spesso si è dimesso
nel corso della sua vita di ministro, salvo essere richiamato subito dopo, perché senza
di lui non si poteva andare avanti. Il re ha la sua diplomazia privata e anche di peggio.
C'è una sua lettera di raccomandazione per un tizio che è stato al suo servizio e che
adesso vuole emigrare in Francia. E il re scrive alla figlia, amatissima, e tuttavia
data in moglie a 15 anni a un vecchio principe francese notoriamente vizioso, perché così
voleva la politica dinastica. Quindi la figlia se ne sta in Francia a fare la principessa
e il re le manda questo suo uomo con una lettera di raccomandazione, in cui dice, ti mando quest'uomo
che venne da me impiegato in una polizia segreta che non dipende che da me. Ecco, dunque già
intanto il re, in un paese costituzionale, ha la sua polizia segreta privata, di cui il
governo non sa niente. Poi dice, ormai quest'uomo però è da molto che mi serve e ormai lo conoscono
tutti, quindi per la polizia segreta non serve più a niente. Te lo mando, vedi se puoi farlo
lavorare. Ricordati che ha molto spirito, ma è un lestofante. Con questo stesso stile
il re cerca di tenere in mano i suoi ministri, finché c'era Cavour non ce la fa. Quando Cavour
muore, e gli uomini che seguono non sono sempre della stessa stazza, il re Vittorio finisce
per contare ancora di più, perché è più difficile per uomini che non sono Cavour
tenergli testa. Ed è difficile anche perché il re fa politica in modo molto spregiudicato.
Quegli stessi ministri che lo giudicavano, ricordate un furfante, un intrigante, un uomo sleale,
beh, avevano torto, avevano ragione. Nello stesso anno il re Vittorio, siamo nel 67, scrive
dei suoi ministri. Li tengo tutti in pugno. Avendo conservato un intero archivio di lettere
che essi mi hanno scritto in epoche diverse, li faccio star zitti e rigare diritto. E dunque
ha i suoi dossier e può continuamente svelare gli alterini dell'uno e dell'altro. Ecco,
Cavour è morto a 51 anni, alla mia età. Si può anche cominciare a capire come mai è morto
giovane, perché non era certamente facile governare con un re di questo genere di sopra.
E però, attenzione, io non vorrei che insistendo su questi aspetti, su questi aneddoti divertenti
e anche un po' scandalosi sulla mediocrità di Vittorio, ci dimenticassimo che poi in realtà
per l'appunto, nei momenti cruciali, Vittorio ha poi sempre trovato il buonsenso e la forza
di sostenere invece il suo governo, anche in situazioni in cui lui personalmente, come dire,
faticava a accettare la linea politica del governo. Dico questo perché vorrei approfittare
di questo incontro su Vittorio per accennare a un aspetto del risorgimento che ieri non
ho avuto tempo di toccare e che è invece cruciale per comprendere l'epoca e gli uomini. E cioè
le grandi polemiche che si hanno negli anni 50, quindi tra la prima e la seconda guerra
d'indipendenza in Piemonte, a proposito del rapporto fra Stato e Chiesa. Avvengono
in quegli anni battaglie politiche importantissime per la modernizzazione del Piemonte e dell'Italia
che ne uscirà. E in queste battaglie il re ha un suo ruolo importante e sacrifica anche
molto. Si tratta in sostanza di affermare il principio caro a Cavour e a tutti i liberali
di allora della libera Chiesa in libero Stato. E dunque di accettare, di far passare una serie
di riforme che mettano fine a privilegi arcaici che la Chiesa ha conservato nei confronti dello
Stato. Nel 1850 sono in discussione alla Camera le leggi siccardi, note così per via del Ministro
che le ha proposte, che in sostanza prevedono di abolire il privilegio del foro ecclesiastico.
Cos'è il foro ecclesiastico? Detto in soldoni è il fatto che i membri del clero, se commettevano
un reato, non venivano giudicati dalla giustizia ordinaria, ma avevano diritto a essere giudicati
da un loro tribunale speciale. Insieme al foro ecclesiastico c'erano altri problemi minori
ma collegati. Per esempio nel Piemonte della Restaurazione esisteva ancora, come nel Medioevo,
il diritto d'asilo nelle Chiese. Per cui il criminale inseguito che si rifugiava in una
Chiesa è che la Polizia non poteva andarlo a prendere. Ma la questione cruciale è il
diritto del clero a una giurisdizione separata, a tribunali separati. Su questo lo scontro
politico è duro, ma in realtà in Parlamento e nel Paese, almeno fra quelli che votano,
c'è una maggioranza chiarissima a favore di questa riforma. E però negli ambienti
cattolici più conservatori la cosa è vista invece con dolore, è vista come un pericolo,
come un attentato alla Chiesa. Ora Vittorio è profondamente cattolico, lui è tutta la
sua famiglia e ha un problema di coscienza concreto ad accettare di firmare, perché alla
fine le deve firmare, delle leggi contro cui la Chiesa è violentamente schierata,
è violentamente ostile. La sua famiglia non gli rende le cose facili, perché il conflitto
di coscienza ce l'hanno tutti, è un conflitto di coscienza molto concreto, c'è la paura che
a far qualcosa contro la Chiesa poi arrivi la punizione divina. La madre gli scrive, questa
è la lettera della mamma al re, il re che è lì che pensa se deve firmare queste leggi
o no. Pensa quale sarebbe il tuo dolore se il signore facesse ammalare gravemente la
tua cara Adele e la moglie, o la tua chicchina e la figlia Clotilde, quella che poi a 15 anni
andrà in sposa eccetera, o il tuo Beto che sarebbe Umberto naturalmente, quello che poi
sarà il re Umberto, il primo figlio maschio. Ecco, di questa riga di una lettera della regina
madre io, come dire, ricorderei da un lato quella cosa che tutti sappiamo ma che è sempre
bello ricordarci, e cioè che anche i re nel privato hanno una loro vita domestica, familiare,
i soprannomi, i bambini chiamati con i nomignoli, Umberto che avrà fatto una gran fatica prima
di riuscire a pronunciare il suo nome e quindi da piccolo era conosciuto come Beto, però poi
l'altra cosa che ricaverei è che appunto la regina madre aveva seriamente paura che se
il re firmava le leggi siccardi sarebbe arrivata la punizione divina e gli sarebbe morto qualcuno.
In queste circostanze Vittorio dà, devo dire, il meglio di sé, fa una cosa che non faceva
mai e che gli dà molto fastidio, si mette a leggere la legge effettivamente prima di
firmarla, si mette a studiarla, ci ragiona su e si convince che la legge è giusta. E può
fare questo perché in realtà si ricorda di quella che è la tradizione della sua dinastia
e su questo vale la pena dispendere un paio di parole per capire come Vittorio si muove
in questo ginepraio delle leggi religiose. La dinastia Sabauda è sempre stata una dinastia
profondamente cattolica, che qui dopo il 48 con lo statuto ci sono i diritti civili anche
per i protestanti, per gli ebrei, ma fino a quel momento nel Piemonte Sabaudo chi non era
cattolico, non aveva diritti civili, era uno stato profondamente ortodosso e che però non
aveva mai avuto nessuna remora a litigare anche violentemente con Roma quando si trattava invece
di ingerenze della Chiesa nella vita politica, nell'amministrazione. Su questo i Savoi hanno
una lunghissima tradizione di conflitti anche estremamente violenti con la Chiesa. E dunque
Vittorio trova questa soluzione, la sua coscienza di cattolico è una cosa, ma in quanto re della
dinastia Sabauda lui non può abdicare a un pezzetto del suo potere, nemmeno per far piacere
al Papa. Tant'è vero che scrive, ho studiato la legge e ho scoperto che è giusta, cito,
e che il Papa non può arrogarsi questa autorità, altrimenti non saremo più padroni in casa nostra.
Dopodiché dice anche, beh sì, io ho firmato ma lo statuto dice che il responsabile della
legge è il ministro, quindi ci andrà Siccardi all'inferno. A questo proposito un pettegolezzo
del solito Henri d'Itville, il solito diplomatico francese a Torino, il quale dice che del re tutti
sanno che non è che tema proprio tanto Dio come dovrebbe, ma ha una gran paura del diavolo.
Non è finita, questa vicenda delle leggi Siccardi e delle successive leggi sui conventi è una
vicenda straordinaria, potremmo stare tutta la sera a parlare di questo. Appena approvate
le leggi Siccardi, a parentesi, per chi di voi viene eventualmente da Torino, a Torino
tuttora le leggi Siccardi sono commemorate in piazza Savoia, non a caso, forse con sottile
ironia, ma comunque non a caso, in piazza Savoia da un obelisco eretto con una sottoscrizione
pubblica alla cui base sta la memorabile frase, la legge è uguale per tutti. Dopodiché appena
approvate le leggi Siccardi muore uno dei ministri, il Santa Rosa, che aveva votato a favore.
E non è tanto il fatto che muore, che però qui ci interessa, quanto il fatto che muore
e il frate che gli portano al capezzale perché ha chiesto i sacramenti, perché è un buon
cattolico come tutti, tutti in Piemonte sono buoni cattolici, tutti quelli che hanno votato
la legge sono buoni cattolici, non è quella la questione. Il ministro Santa Rosa chiama
un prete perché sta morendo, gli portano un frate dell'ordine dei serviti e il frate
dice no, io non ti posso dare la soluzione. Hai firmato la legge Siccardi, non ti do la
soluzione, il ministro muore senza la soluzione. Dopodiché non vogliono nemmeno dargli sepoltura
cristiana. Succede una bagarre memorabile, Cavour, che in quel momento non è ancora il
governo ma è già un uomo potentissimo e che era amico personale del ministro morto,
suscita un enorme scandalo per questa faccenda e convince il governo a prendere misure adeguate.
Non solo il padre Pittavino che è il responsabile della mancata soluzione, ma l'intero ordine
dei serviti viene cacciato da Torino. Dopodiché non è finita nemmeno qui perché l'arcivescovo
di Torino, Franzoni, che è già noto, come dire, dà già molto fastidio ai liberali perché
è un reazionario deciso, ha predicato contro lo statuto, contro il liberalismo e così via,
al momento in cui passano le leggi Siccardi, dopo aver fatto una violentissima opposizione,
l'arcivescovo di Torino invita pubblicamente il clero a disobbedire alla legge. Dopodiché
succede una cosa che a sentirla nell'Italia di oggi ci fa trasecolare, l'arcivescovo viene
arrestato, spedito in fortezza, condannato e espulso dal regno. E su tutte queste cose
Vittorio mette la firma perché è riuscito ad avere la lucidità di capire che la sua coscienza
di cattolico in quel momento non c'entra niente con l'autonomia dello Stato dalle
ingerenze. Però beninteso, è sempre interessato andare a vedere nel concreto di cosa si sta
discutendo. Due anni dopo il governo Cavour tenta di fare un altro passo avanti sulla via
della laicizzazione dello Stato, tenta di fare una cosa che nell'Italia di allora appare
stupefacente e cioè introdurre il matrimonio civile, la possibilità cioè di sposarsi anche
non in chiesa. Su questo lo scontro è ancora più duro e su questo il re non cede. Non cede
anche perché, e qui vediamo quello che vi dicevo prima, cosa vuol dire avere un re che
fa politica anche per conto suo alle spalle del governo, e qui lo fa con le migliori intenzioni
per tranquillizzare la sua coscienza di cattolico, il re Vittorio intrattiene una corrispondenza
col Papa per sapere come deve regolarsi su questa legge del matrimonio civile che sta passando
in Parlamento. Il Papa gli risponde con delle lettere meravigliose in cui lo accusa, visto
che sta permettendo che nel suo paese passi questa cosa, il Papa accusa il re Vittorio
di essere, cito, fautore di comunismo e di sovversione sociale. Di fronte a questo il
re decide che la sua coscienza non gli permette di firmare e in effetti mette il veto alla legge
che non passa. Non è finita, il governo Cavour ostinatamente va a cercare altri ambiti in cui
bisogna intervenire. Presenta una legge per la soppressione degli ordini religiosi di troppo,
diciamo così. Il Paese è pieno di conventi, è pieno di ordini religiosi, molti hanno una
funzione attiva di assistenza, di insegnamento, quelli non verranno toccati, ma quelli invece
improduttivi che hanno enormi proprietà terriere, che appunto è tempo di mettere in circolazione
perché il Paese sta crescendo economicamente e deve modernizzarsi, e gli altri ordini verranno
soppressi. Anche qui cogliamo in pieno la difficoltà di un governo che cerca di portare
avanti la sua politica e che deve poi però ottenere la firma di un re il quale fa politica
per conto suo sotto banco. Ovviamente il mondo cattolico è furioso nei confronti di questa legge
e il re negozia di nuovo col Papa, negozia con l'episcopato piemontese, e a un certo punto dopo
che la legge sostenuta dal governo è già passata alla Camera, viene fuori che il re è d'accordo con
i vescovi per presentare una proposta alternativa. Una cosa del genere ovviamente farebbe cadere il
governo e infatti fa cadere il governo. Cavour si dimette immediatamente quando viene a sapere
che il re è d'accordo con l'episcopato per presentare una proposta alternativa a quella
del governo. A quel punto il governo non può più stare ovviamente. Cavour si dimette con un discorso
che fa riferimenti minacciosi a quei sovrani che non hanno saputo attuare le riforme al momento
giusto, in passato è già successo e se ne sono dovuti pentire. Dopodiché, come potete
immaginare, il re è costretto a richiamare Cavour perché un'altra maggioranza non c'è,
e poi la cosa si risolve in modo mirabolante perché Cavour e Rattazzi hanno in realtà una
lettera del re, scritta prima che venisse fuori tutto lo scandalo, quando si era appena cominciato
a parlare di queste leggi per la soppressione dei conventi. Cavour e Rattazzi hanno una lettera
del re in cui il re dice sono d'accordo, sono d'accordissimo con questa legge, anzi
fatela ancora più severa, sopprimetene ancora di più. Poi lui aveva cambiato idea, ma loro
hanno conservato la lettera, è così che si faceva politica evidentemente allora. Dopodiché
vanno dal re con la lettera e poi fanno il bel gesto di dire noi mai e poi mai la pubblicheremmo
assolutamente, anzi la restituiamo a vostra maestà. Però vostra maestà ci faccia due conti
e Vittorio firma la legge. Anche perché l'opinione pubblica è totalmente a favore
e il re si sta accorgendo che sta perdendo il consenso dell'opinione pubblica. Con la
sua opposizione a questa legge ci sono episodi anche preoccupanti, battaglioni della Guardia
Nazionale che quando sono invitati dai loro comandanti a gridare viva il re stanno zitti
e poi c'è una tremenda lettera di D'Azeglio, ex primo ministro al re, in cui gli dice guarda
che appunto comportandoti in questo modo, boicottando questa legge, stai rovinando la
tua immagine e tutto quello che hai fatto finora. Cito da D'Azeglio.
Un intrigo di frati è riuscito in un giorno a distruggere l'opera del suo regno, ad agitare
il paese, a scuotere lo statuto, oscurare il suo nome di leale, il suo del re appunto,
regalantuomo. Ed Azzeglio conclude, il Piemonte soffre tutto, ma di essere di nuovo messo sotto
il giogo pretino no per Dio. Dopodiché il re firma e cosa succede? Il papa lo scomunica
e Don Bosco, perché c'è anche Don Bosco nella Torino dell'epoca, che sta facendo
un enorme lavoro nei quartieri operai di sostegno agli orfani, ai ragazzi e così via,
e però in questa circostanza si comporta come magari noi preferiremmo che non si fosse
comportato, perché Don Bosco sogna più volte un funerale alla reggia e ogni volta scrive
al re per dirglielo, guarda che ho sognato un funerale alla reggia, sei ancora in tempo a
non firmarle le leggi. Il re firma e voi immaginate come si può essere sentito quest'uomo
che ha firmato un po' perché altrimenti il paese va all'aria, non c'è altro governo
possibile, un po' perché l'hanno ricattato con la lettera che aveva avuto la leggerezza
di scrivere prima dicendo che lui era d'accordo, un po' perché alla fin fine si è convinto
che effettivamente va bene così. Ha firmato, però la sua coscienza non era tanto tranquilla.
Don Bosco gli scrive queste cose e nel giro di un mese muoiono la madre, la moglie di
Vittorio, di parto, e il fratello. Ecco, immaginatevi come si può essere sentito
quest'uomo. Però ha firmato e non torna indietro, e anzi, quando gli arriva la notizia
che il papa lo ha scomunicato, trova l'energia per reagire da par suo, come avrebbero fatto
i suoi antenati di una volta. Il papa mi ha scomunicato e dice, benissimo, finché mi
scomunica, come in questo caso, per ragioni puramente temporali, politiche, cito dal re
Vittorio, voi mi scuserete, me ne fotto.
Come si comporta Vittorio nella grande crisi, la grande crisi che abbiamo raccontato meglio
ieri, quella in cui Cavour compie il grosso della sua opera, la crisi del 59, Vittorio
si comporta bene in quel caso. Sa stare al fianco di Cavour, sa aspettare con pazienza che Napoleone
III si decida finalmente a aiutare il Piemonte a fare la guerra contro l'Austria. Vittorio,
non dimentichiamocelo, si gioca molto in quel caso. Suo padre, dieci anni prima, ha perso
la guerra e è stato costretto a abdicare. E il re sa benissimo che lui sul piatto sta
mettendo quello, sta mettendo il suo trono, non dimentichiamocelo neanche noi, naturalmente,
quando in qualche modo siamo tentati di giudicarlo. C'è una meravigliosa frase che lui dice a
Cavour a un certo punto. Egregio Conte, voi avete 150.000 lire di rendita, tipo un milione
di euro, grosso modo, come potere d'acquisto, le entrate di Cavour. E qualunque cosa accada
per voi nulla cambia, ma sappiate che io non voglio ritrovarmi dove è finito mio padre.
Dunque il re sa benissimo che si sta giocando molto. Si gioca molto nel caso che le cose
vadano male, gli austriaci vincano. E poi c'è sempre anche l'altra ipotesi, lo spettro
del comunismo che evocavamo ieri, o perlomeno lo spettro dei mazziniani, della rivoluzione
democratica, della repubblica. Potrebbe anche andare a finire in quel modo lì, chi lo sa.
E anche in quel caso lì Vittorio ha tutto da perdere. E lo dice, se va tutto bene io divento
il re dell'alta Italia. Non ci pensavano ancora neanche lontanamente che pochi mesi dopo avrebbero
avuto l'Italia unita. Pensavano al Lombardo Veneto. Ma Vittorio dice, se va tutto bene divento
il re dell'alta Italia, ma se va in quell'altro modo, se vincono i mazziniani, io divento
Munsiu Savoia. Cioè il signor Savoia, privato cittadino come tutti gli altri. Dunque, si gioca
molto anche lui, senza alcun dubbio, e però sa fare la sua parte. Va detto che fa la sua
parte anche perché gli va veramente bene da un punto di vista la situazione. Finalmente
si fa la guerra. Vittorio ha avuto un'educazione militare, si considera un militare prima di tutto,
la guerra gli piace moltissimo, perfino più della caccia, non la può fare sempre però
la guerra, quindi si accontenta di massacrare stambecchi. Ma lui adora l'idea della guerra
e quando finalmente nel 59 si fa la guerra è felice. È stato anni lì a rodere il freno
aspettando di fare la guerra. Farò ancora una citazione. La regina Vittoria, che lo aveva
ricevuto qualche anno prima e che parla molto di lui nel suo diario, potete immaginarvi l'impressione
che ha fatto Vittorio alla regina Vittoria. La regina Vittoria sostiene che il re le ha
detto, io non amo fare il re. Se non posso fare la guerra, mi farò frate. E Vittoria
poi continua meravigliosamente, dice, sì, lo diceva con quel suo vocione, roteando gli
occhi, povero uomo. Penso che sia infelice e molto da compiangere. Più che a un re dei
nostri giorni assomiglia a un cavaliere medievale che viva della sua spada. Il 59
quindi è il grande momento di Vittorio. È alla testa dell'esercito, lo conduce in
guerra, sfida il pericolo, si fa sparare addosso, è veramente coraggioso, eroico, riesce
perfino a vincere una battaglia, la battaglia di San Martino, che verrà poi celebrata dalla
storiografia italiana come gemella della grande vittoria di Solferino che avviene lo stesso giorno.
In realtà è una battaglia un po' più piccola San Martino, ma insomma Vittorio fa la guerra,
la fa bene, la fa da eroe forse più che da stratega, ma insomma è nel suo elemento, fa
la sua parte. Cavour, che è rimasto a Torino, è sempre preoccupato che il re faccia qualche
sciocchezza. Egli scrive delle lettere di buoni consigli. Il re non è tanto contento.
In risposta a una di queste lettere, Cavour gli dice, mi raccomando, si faccia consigliare,
si metta intorno della gente brava, in gamba. E il re gli risponde, questa è un po' lunghetta
ma la cito. Lei mi dice che devo essere circondato da tanti geni che mi impediscano di fare delle
bestialità. Pare che lei mi considera un grande asino nel mio mestiere. Se lei mi parla ancora
una volta così, vedrà cosa farò. Manderò via tutti d'intorno a me quelli che vi sono e mi
circonderò di meno capaci ancora. E farò vedere io se non so fare il mio mestiere senza tanti
consiglieri. Dove la cosa che noterei è il mio mestiere. Vittorio è convinto che lui, sì certo
è un re, ma il suo vero mestiere è fare la guerra. Per sua sfortuna non ha avuto moltissime occasioni di
farlo, ma lì nel 59 l'ha fatta sul serio e si è divertito un mondo. Poi naturalmente c'è sempre
il problema che accanto a lui c'è Napoleone III. Sono alleati, ma la Francia conta molto di più.
L'esercito francese è molto più grande, fa la parte del leone, Napoleone III è quello più famoso,
più conosciuto, è lui sulle prime pagine e poi è lui che decide di fermarsi, di fare l'armistizio di
Villafranca. Ecco, Vittorio la patisce un po' questa cosa di aver vicino l'imperatore. La patisce
anche perché, in perfetta buona fede, lui dice, ma chi è questo che è appena arrivato? E' un parvenu.
Chi è dopo tutto quest'uomo, questo bischero? L'ultimo venuto dei sovrani d'Europa, un intruso
tra di noi. Farebbe meglio a ricordare chi è lui e chi sono io, il capo della prima e più antica
dinastia regnante d'Europa. Ed è vero tecnicamente che i Savoia risalgono nel tempo abbastanza indietro
da essere più antichi, non dei buona parte che fa ridere, ma anche di quasi tutte le
altre dinastie regnanti europee. Dopodiché, anche qui, Vittorio ha anche questo aspetto
che è uno che parla facilmente, dice tante cose, dice anche cose contraddittorie fra
loro. L'ultimo è arrivato fra noi, questo sembra ancora il re dei vecchi tempi, il re
di diritto divino. Vittorio in realtà, a norma dello statuto, regna per grazia di Dio e
per volontà della nazione, ma lui lasciato a se stesso è ancora quel per grazia di Dio
che sente più forte. Potrebbe benissimo essere un re dei vecchi tempi. E però ha anche capito
che i tempi sono cambiati, che i tempi sono cambiati e che non sono più di moda i re che
pretendono di comandare senza Parlamento, senza elezioni, senza libera stampa, senza consenso
popolare. Ha capito che non sono più di moda. Ed è il motivo per cui, pur con mille
preoccupazioni, alla fine, quando Garibaldi parte per andare a buttare giù i Borboni e
si vede che ci sta riuscendo e che il regno borbonico crolla come un castello di carte,
bene, il re viene messo in croce dai conservatori che gli dicono, ma come, siete alleati con
Garibaldi, con un rivoluzionario con la camicia rossa? E Vittorio ha quest'altra risposta
geniale sul fatto che, appunto, va bene, Garibaldi è d'accordo, ma i Borboni sono caduti perché
è il loro stesso popolo che li ha fatti cadere. E dice, i popoli hanno il diritto di mandare
i loro re a farsi fottere.
Abbiamo fatto tardi, tardissimo. Io voglio ancora raccontare rapidamente un aspetto della
vita di Vittorio che non è più politico, anche se si intreccia con la politica, ma
è più privato. Vale la pena di ricordarlo, perché altrimenti sarebbero soltanto gli
aspetti più negativi dell'uomo nel suo privato, nel suo modo di parlare, di comportarsi, che
ci restano nella memoria. Vittorio in realtà è molto simpatico da altri punti di vista.
I diplomatici stranieri sono, per esempio, esterrefatti perché questo re, che si vanta
di discendere dalla più antica dinastia regnante d'Europa, detesta le formalità, detesta i
ricevimenti, odia l'etichetta, non sopporta la vita di corte, soprattutto detesta i banchetti.
Scrive Lideville, mangia una sola volta al giorno, ma abbondantemente, e preferisce i cibi
grossolani e popolari. Quando è costretto ad assistere a un banchetto ufficiale, a un
pranzo di corte, non svolge nemmeno il tovagliolo, non tocca cibo. Con le mani appoggiate sull'elsa
della sciabola, esamina i convitati, senza cercare di nascondere l'impazienza e la noia.
Appena può, scappa da palazzo e va a rifugiarsi alla tenuta della Mandria, vicino a Torino, che
lui ha fatto sistemare come tenuta privata, come residenza privata sua e della sua famiglia,
o meglio, delle sue due famiglie. Perché il re ha due famiglie. È sposato con Maria
Adelaide, che gli dà parecchi figli, tra cui Umberto, che sarà poi il suo erede, e che
poi a un certo punto muore. E fin da quando è ancora principe ereditario, ha 27 anni, si è
appena sposato ufficialmente, fin da allora ha una relazione fissa con quel personaggio,
diventato poi celeberrimo nel folklore piemontese, che è la bella Rosina, la bella Rusin, come
si dice in piemontese. Vittorio in realtà ha avuto avventure innumerevoli, ma con Rosina
ha avuto una relazione stabile che è durata tutta la vita. Lei era la figlia di un sottufficiale,
lui l'ha conosciuta e si è messo con lei quando lei aveva 14 anni. Non stupiamoci,
all'epoca non si fanno questi problemi. Ho ricordato già prima che anche la principessa
Clotilde, figlia di Vittorio, viene data in sposa al principe Gerolamo Napoleone, detto
plom plom, quando lei aveva soltanto 15 anni. Le regole sono diverse a quell'epoca. Quando
Rosina ha 14 anni, il principe la scopre, si mette con lei, se la porta subito a palazzo,
già un anno dopo è nata la prima figlia e lui avrà sempre questa seconda famiglia accanto
a quella ufficiale. Quando si organizza la residenza privata alla Mandria, la moglie Maria
Delaide è ancora viva e lui fa mettere la stanza di Maria Delaide a un estremo del castello
e la stanza di Rosina all'altro estremo e la sua in mezzo. Quando rimane vedovo, avrà
ancora altre avventure, ma non si risposa più, nonostante il tentativo con la principessa
Mary che ricordavamo all'inizio, non si risposa più e la liaison con la Rosina diventa la sua
vera famiglia, un legame stabile. Tanto che comincia subito a parlare di sposarla. Immaginate
la faccia di Cavour. Quando il re comincia seriamente a parlare di sposare la Rosina,
Cavour che è tutto impegnato a creare l'alleanza con l'Inghilterra, con la regina Vittoria,
con la Francia e così via, si mette le mani nei pochi capelli che ha e dice al re che non
se ne parla neanche, non la può sposare, non può sposare la sua amante figlia di un
sergente che gli ha già dato dei figli. Ecco, il re, questo è tipico di Vittorio, prova
a fregarlo. Gli dice ma io in realtà l'ho già sposata. Cavour sviene. Poi salta fuori
che non è vero e Cavour gli fa una paternale, il re si sottomette e per il momento non la
sposa. Ancora anni dopo, morto Cavour, succede che il re parla di questa faccenda, si lamenta
che non gli hanno lasciato sposare la Rosina e dice me l'ha impedito, parla di Cavour, un
birbante che si diceva mio amico e se ne pentì poi bene. Lo stile della relazione
del re con Rosina lo potremmo ricordare per esempio con una citazione di una lettera che
le scrive. Siamo nel 55, sono gli anni di Cavour, sposarla non se ne parla nemmeno, però
stanno insieme il più possibile. C'è la bambina che cresce bene, poi nascerà un altro
figlio. Il re scrive una lunga lettera in cui parla di tante cose e si conclude così.
Ciao cara Rosina, ti mando tanti basi. Ti ho rubato una cosa prima che tu sia partita,
non te ne sei accorta. Chissà cosa l'avrà rubato, qui ognuno può fare le sue ipotesi.
Amami la metà di quello che ti amo io. Tanti basi a te e alla piccola. Il tuo vittorio.
dopo di che passa qualche anno, si fa l'Italia, lui diventa re d'Italia, Cavour muore. Una
delle prime cose che il re rimette in discussione è che lui vuole sposare la Rosina. E stavolta
ci riesce. La sposa. La sposa con il matrimonio che si usava all'epoca per i sovrani che si
sposavano al di sotto del loro rango. Un matrimonio perfettamente valido ma che esclude ovviamente
la sposa e i figli dagli onori regali, quindi lei non diventa regina, i figli non saranno
mai eredi al trono, però la sposa. Gli tocca scrivere alla figlia Clotilde, in Francia,
moglie di Plonplon, per spiegare alla figlia che stavolta ha deciso, sposa la Rosina. Ovviamente
la figlia sa tutto, tutti sanno tutto. Come la prendano è un altro conto. Cito ancora,
e poi sto davvero finendo, cito ancora la lettera con cui il re scrive alla figlia per spiegarle
che stavolta sposa la Rosina. Perché la sposa? Perché l'ha promesso, si è impegnato. Non
può non farlo. Non ho mai amato al mondo, che è la tua santissima madre, e poi questa.
E poi continuo raccontando di questo amore, di questa storia straordinaria. Cito a caso,
un terribile destino, un grande amore. Ora, cara Checchina, continuo a chiamarla con soprannome
di quando era bambina la figlia, ora cara Checchina sono pronto a sposarla. La Rosina,
dice, è così delicata, lei non me l'ha mai chiesto. Io però, proprio per questo, proprio
vedendo che lei è così fine, non me l'ha mai chiesto, io gliel'ho promesso. Quella
promessa? Che come uomo onorato e soldato, mi lega fino alla morte. Non volermi male.
Ed abbi un poco di carità per il tuo misero papalino. Ho bisogno, ho diritto di avere
un poco di pace. Dopodiché, effettivamente, sposa la Rosina e a partire da quel momento,
appena può, se ne va tranquillamente in pantofole a fumare la pipa insieme alla Rosina e ai ragazzini
che crescono, e scappa dagli impegni di Stato. Ecco, l'uomo è curioso, come vedete. C'è questo
grande appetito carnale in tutte le direzioni, c'è questo disprezzo per le forme, c'è il
sentimentalismo che traspare anche da quest'ultima lettera che vi ho letto, c'è una retorica
ingenua e sotto però un solido buonsenso, una certa rozzezza che spaventa le regine
Vittoria di turno e che però magari piace anche alla gente. Ecco, tutti questi tratti
allontanano totalmente Vittorio da Cavour, che non avrebbe potuto essere più diverso,
e lo avvicinano invece a Garibaldi. Vittorio e Garibaldi erano supposizioni politiche opposte,
ci sono stati momenti in cui Vittorio se avesse potuto far impiccare Garibaldi
lo avrebbe magari fatto volentieri, e tuttavia ogni volta che sono venuti a contatto
si è scoperto che tutto sommato come tipi umani una certa rozza familiarità fra loro
nasceva, si assomigliavano abbastanza, pur essendo nati ai due capi estremi della scala
sociale. E io, che non sapevo bene come finire stasera, finisco così. Domani parleremo
di Garibaldi, parleremo di un uomo che da Vittorio non era poi così diverso tutto sommato
come potrebbe sembrare. Grazie.